the Joe Rogan experience but isn't that
bad to be talking to people that would
say isn't it
is it bad we talk to people so much to
[ __ ] diet yeah the shitty diet Duncan
and I were talking about the other day
about like finding information online
just constantly be inundated with
stories of horrific things and bad
things and terrible things and ugly
things that it's a bad diet it's a bad
like mind eye and that's like you're so
right that that means you think you're
like immunity that you are who you are
and it's just some stuff you're
experiencing but much like if you eat
healthy foods your body feels better I
think if you concentrate on healthy
things and interesting things and
fascinating things and not horseshit I
think you're giving yourself a better
mental diet totally I think if you
consume too much of anything it's bad
right so consuming too much of even tuku
too much positive information can be
[ __ ] detrimental because you can get
delusional yes so you have to have some
semblance of a balance of how you and
Jess but the people that only ingest
negative they're like people only eat
candy if you grown adults and for like
ten years you only ate candy yeah your
body would be a mess a photo just barely
alive if you just had to live off
Snickers bars how much nutrition isn't a
Snickers bar like I want to do something
with that dude who did the 30 days with
the big supersize me yes guy hey bro do
this just eat nothing but sniffs how
long you stay at aspires to a point
that's why your hunger I guess they're
delicious
yeah the ramen I love us in my favor
they're great to take on hikes too by
the way what really yeah a lot of
nutrition and they burn in sugar man yes
[ __ ] it hiking up mountains and [ __ ]
people love Snickers bars Wow
but hey I think even the Snickers people
would tell you don't live off that [ __ ]
stupid you can't live off us today isn't
that interesting like there's a food you
eat that you cannot live off of yes
because all food at one point you had to
eat to live off of how many days do you
think you could go with only eating
Snickers bars and should this be the
sober October challenge
yes first of all yes and second of I
what if we know Reese would die Bert
will die but I mean that is what it is
if you only could eat Snickers bars and
water two weeks two weeks two weeks
without your body malfunctioning I think
something's gonna happen yeah there's a
post I just found from like two years
ago where people ask this question it
was a discussion if someone did the math
you get the eight about twelve to get
the caloric intake to get that 2,000 a
day twelve a day just for 2,000 calories
how many days could you survive ion I
mean that's up to you bro let's think
about that twelve hours a day
holy [ __ ] how long do you think okay the
problem with that is like everyone is
not coming from the same starting point
that's the biggest issue you have to
have those three twin guys separated
Snickers to life and dies you guys need
to cut you guys need to control you guys
need some sort of hero they would be the
test just feed them give them a million
dollars each give them nothing but
Snickers till someone's on the verge of
death till somebody taps tap out [ __ ]
honey
Daisy thing you go on only Snickers hi
say two weeks is probably the human body
will start to shut down I wonder maybe
you could go a long time well let me say
this you could you could [ __ ] find
this there's a dude that's been eating
just pizza for like 25 years
breakfast lunch and dinner well fine
dude that he's just pepperoni pizza I
respect that it's like [ __ ] it my
parents told me what to do my whole life
and I'm a grown man now [ __ ] I paid
sevareid a just crying and eating pizza
never saw this journalist try to get him
to have like a piece of green leafy
greens puked on camera [ __ ] unless it's
basil and a nice sauce
get that [ __ ] green [ __ ] of a pizza
for 20 years something like that's the
same way was it Jamie was it 25 years he
says he has a one boy Raisin Bran a week
glue glue cheese chewing down all that
dough that delicious holy [ __ ] 25 years
he does have diabetes of course he does
duh
call it me surprise how the [ __ ] sorry
buddy for laughing at your diabetes but
how the fat all not sorry
how the [ __ ] does someone eat nothing
but that glue for 25 that's the cat exam
studies 48 guy should be doing YouTube
videos so what do they call they call
him skinny fat on there was an article
to call him like he's you know ski you
know skinny fat right yeah he looks
remarkably good for someone who's only
in pizza for 25 years it might be
something to it but they say skinny fat
people look skinny skinny fat we're like
the body doesn't show any signs but the
insides [ __ ] murdered it's torn apart
yeah well there's muscles nothing's
there yeah that's why you can look small
but you don't have anything there right
skinny fat people your limbs are barely
hanging on threads you know certain
people like you hug them and you're like
oh my god god is nothing there you're so
frail so honey when you when you hold
that's like when I take pictures after
shows it's a how-to people yeah you know
and you grabs and you feel and some
people you feeling like wow that's
[ __ ] weird it's weird it's weird
you're like I'm [ __ ] just lumping
disks sticks cover with jello
[Applause]